you were so much fun at your panel and
you had a lot of people asking you to
reenact iconic scenes from your films
and you did it well that was fun what's
up fun for you being up there because I
know you don't do conventions too often
yeah this is my second or third one gosh
what nice people I must be in Canada yes
you are
I know that you worked with John
Travolta on the poison rose recently
he's going to be at the convention as
well what was like working with him this
great guy is so generous friendly his
funny interesting guy it was great good
fun I also know your Encino man co-star
Sean Astin is going to be at the
convention as well have you run into him
yet no not yet no you looking for
say hi to Sean from the other night soon
um what's it like when people come up to
you and ask you about Encino man and say
it's like one of their favorite films
cuz it's my favorite film of yours
it's a pleasure it warms my heart it
makes me think I'm old no it was
meaningful to somebody in a way that has
permanence I guess it makes people happy
yeah could you see there being a sequel
in the future to Encino man I don't know
why not I mean everything's getting
remade remade rebooted rebooted mated I
know is there one specific role that you
would love to see that you'd love to
revisit
to revisit yeah I'd like to do a sequel
and to play that character again oh yeah
I really like Rick Rick O'Connell and
the mommy there's more to them the the
we could we could can we go a little
further with that if we wanted to that's
good the fans weren't super happy with
the most recent remake so we need you
back
I'm glad hear you say that and from your
mouth to the powers that be easier I'm
in the book I've a lot of power just so
you know to make this happen how great
is it knowing that your fans are so
excited to see you on all these new
television shows and doom control
they're calling it the Brenna sauce have
you heard that that's a funny name yeah
I've heard that I take that as a vote of
confidence appreciated that's nice it's
nice yeah awesome
well thank you so much it was so nice
meeting you you were so great up there